LARRY P. ARNN: Every
time you make a choice,
it places a mark on your soul,
and it makes you what you are.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So this is a class about ethics.
What is that?
SPEAKER 2: The study
of human character--
what one ought to do.
LARRY P. ARNN: What do
we mean by character?
SPEAKER 2: The recurrent
habits of action
that you follow
through in your life.
LARRY P. ARNN: You mean habits?
SPEAKER 3: It's the
steady state of--
it's formed through habits,
so you have the steady state
through which you'll
act in a particular way
because of the kind
of character you have.
LARRY P. ARNN: I
argue that ethics is
the study of how best to live.
Why is ethics important?
SPEAKER 4: Because we're trying
to figure out how to be good.
LARRY P. ARNN: Good.
Good is important.
Give me another definition
of that word, [? Juan. ?]
SPEAKER 5: Of ethics?
LARRY P. ARNN: Yeah.
SPEAKER 5: I would say
development of your character.
LARRY P. ARNN: Character,
the Greek word [GREEK]..
SPEAKER 6: Is it like a mark?
LARRY P. ARNN: Yeah.
Mark, etch, engrave, tattoo.
Not paint on the surface.
Dig in.
Character is dug in,
something deep in us.
It's what [? Stephen ?]
said down there.
He said, learning
how to be good.
And that is the whole question.
We almost never ask
that question today.
We introduce the young to
learning, where in education it
means lead forth.
We leave off forth.
And that means we introduce
the young to education
with an invitation
for them to become
whatever they want to be.
But they could become
ostriches, maybe,
but they wouldn't be
very good at that.
It's the reason ethics
is a big subject.
It is the first subject.
And this is the first book
ever written about it.
And I will tell you, back
in the Paleolithic era,
when I was in graduate
school, in the first class I
had with a great man, he
called this one of the greatest
books ever written.
So somebody read
the first sentence.
Was does it say?
SPEAKER 7: "Every art and
every inquiry, and likewise
every action and choice,
seems to aim at some good,
and hence it has
been beautifully said
that the good is that at
which all things aim."
LARRY P. ARNN: Now look at
the nouns in that sentence.
They're all fundamental words.
What does art mean?
SPEAKER 2: Technical knowledge.
Yeah.
Yeah, a craft.
Something you make.
LARRY P. ARNN: So you
said the word "technical,"
and the Greek word is [GREEK].
That's making.
It doesn't mean
in the background
is Raphael's School of Athens.
That's fine art.
That's high art.
But it has in
common with whoever
made that glass right
there that it was produced.
It was made.
It was designed and
executed according to skill
and with the purpose in mind.
And the first claim
is that every time we
do that, we aim at some good--
that we're good.
We're going to have to
figure out what that means.
What's an inquiry?
SPEAKER 8: Just a question.
LARRY P. ARNN: It's something
more than a question, isn't it?
The word is
"methodose" in Greek.
And a method.
In other words, undertake it.
It's just, heck, I wonder
what's going to happen tomorrow,
and then you go on
about your life.
That's not an inquiry.
We're going to find
out what ethics is.
This is an inquiry.
And also, remember, we're
going to encounter in book one,
Aristotle saying the reason
this book is to be read
is to become good.
This is an urgent inquiry.
And this inquiry,
like every other,
he says, aims at some good.
Action, what's that word?
Praxis, you know
what that means?
SPEAKER 9: Yeah, it's doing.
LARRY P. ARNN: Yeah.
We get practice, practical
from it, practice.
Every time we act.
And then the last is choice.
If you had to pick
one of these words,
that word is crucial
because choice
is at the center of the
building of character.
In this word "choice" is found
the basis of human freedom.
Because it's not just that
you're free to choose,
it's also that your
choices matter very much.
And the claim is, every
time you make a choice,
it places a mark on your soul,
and it makes you what you are.
And nobody makes
them all perfect.
Anybody who's determined to
make them well, every day,
and having failed some
that day, start again
in the morning, those
people become good.
And we'll find out, not
only good, also happy.
I'm Larry Arnn, president
of Hillsdale College.
You will find, if you look
at our online courses,
that they cover the whole
range of human learning,
all the high and fundamental
things everyone needs to know.
They are free because
we have always
wished to provide sound
learning to anyone
who wishes to have it.